Hey guys, how's it going? It's Justine & Jenna, and today we are gonna be making ice cream
I love ice cream and I love ice cream so much the video that we did on Jenna's channel a while ago
We made that mold ice cream-
/oh my god, the peppermint rolled ice cream?
We're not allowed to make it
We found that I was like we can't make it because I could not control myself-
/ I mean, she was
drinking it! It wasn't even in the ice cream form it was just a liquid and she was like gotta strong-
/ Things happened,
I had the worst stomachache ever and
We're not gonna make that mistake again, but today, /
- Wow!
Have you picked this up?
-Yeah, I picked it up decided here. We are making ice cream
We are going to be using a ball now
You basically put ice cream mix into this ball, and then you put ice on the other side of it
And then you roll the ball for about 20 minutes, and then guess what? you have ice cream
I did that earlier, and I knocked over the whole during- Um? This is ice cream solvent?
Yeah, this is recommended on Amazon, but man this box has been destroyed
This is if you want to take your ball in the pool. So don't float are you wait wait wait?
It's inflatable well. We don't need that right now
You will blow this for me. Yo I hate it hurts. My ears shoot. Me too. Well we might not listen up
We might not inflate our balls, but that penology in play that crap. This is a thing well
We might have to I'll blow it. I'm so confused
Well, let me explain to you
I'm confused. I don't have to do that. We can just kick this around is it. Did you freeze it?
That's not how it works
So there's two sides one of the sides you put the heaviest and the other side you put the green
This is fun. I wish I can invent some fun oh
It's a little dirty
Yeah, it does something fair. Well. You don't eat from this side
This is where the ice goes this does look dirty what have you wash it. I've got questions
hands look
I feel like this is fake
They scoop that right out of that Breyers, candle yeah
But I just don't feel like this is a fitting for like what this is like. It's just a beard picture. Okay anyway
I can't get over this big big big oh
No you can't make a big mint because I can't control myself oh
Cool I'm gonna wash this because I'm gonna want to eat this ice cream all right I will
Investigate what we do welcome interactions with a basic vanilla. I think we need a pint of cream Oh
Pure and simple wrestle a speck vanilla, yep line up lines of cream yes pint
Whoops. What is your pass wait wait one third? Oh really one third cup. I thought I said one one third cup Wow
Good thing you're here
This isn't gonna come from an extract you have a little bit. Yep one in one half
To sugar up everywhere that moves that I don't know what that was how much was that well
Why are you doing that because one of the things that you're doing right now? I'm putting a little vanilla in there. Well don't
Use that because I use that um. Oh yeah, that's the problem. I use this unbox stuff
It's not clean part makes Holly burst into flames
Pardon me well at first I
Didn't really had a ready to roll doing rice in the bowl
Yeah, get break at the rice ready pour the mixture into the metal sill
into the top for expansion
This is where putting the ice and the silver inside of it is where the ice cream goes. Thank God I
Don't want to drop the ball on this one oh
Yeah, hold up straight
Put it about an inch give it. That's an inch
Yes, yeah, yeah, it's good. It's good enough. So now what we're gonna. Do it's gonna close this up
You don't want our cream coming yeah, now. We're home. We gotta go play with the ball. What does Maddie's gonna like it?
I'll be rolling this and all of his pee that's disgusting well. It's facts put the foot they've left
Let's put the inflator on light it up
This is like did you like
Oh God yeah breathe let's just go around
You're covering to put the ball in its protective gear it just goes like this
Then you this is absolutely ridiculous. Can you imagine having this at a pool party?
tight squeeze around this book
This is fun
So it's done yet
Oh
I quit oh
I don't think I'm ready
This is still this is not even cold. I think we still have like 10 minutes to go. Oh Oh
Gosh delicious. You realize you just like the boy
I just lick the ball you guys like the but you guys are just like dog pee I
Just rolled this ball, I'm crap. What do I do all right? What do I do? I want to make us ice cream?
You know turn the dryer
that is an
Absolutely incredible idea except. It'll break your dryer. It's just an empty out
some of the water from the ice
I think I'm enjoying what am I immature?
SLU turn doesn't say rolled around and dog through all
But if I put it on like this is a bad idea
You look miserable, this is what I look like it's a lock
We've been doing this for like 20 minutes or so and I don't want to do it anymore here we go
It's so good here, I'll take a bite of you give me the camera I
Think I might a few go but like this is rolling around and poop and pee mm-hmm
No Maddie
So I will say that if I have more patience this would work really well
I'm quite impressed if you guys want to check this out
I'll put a link the description to Amazon where you can get it. This is not sponsored I
Bought this because I thought it was gonna be a lot more fun, but I'll tell you what man
Actually work though like it's all like stuck to the sides
Like it's definitely perfect
Is it impressive? Thanks for watching